[Music]
welcome to another episode of i've got a
question today's question is this a lot
of the information you share seems
unbelievable a bit of a stretch are you
sure it's true
well first of all let me say that we are
a christian ministry and we are not
doing any of this with the intention of
deception by christian standards that
would be wrong and contradictory but we
are human and humans make mistakes
so we're not above reproach
you know one of the laws that governed
israel was the testimony of two or three
witnesses you could say that we're
abiding by that today we are not asking
you to believe what we say just because
we say it
but we are asking you to be like the
bereans and the apostle paul describes
these people this way these were more
fair-minded than those in thessalonica
in that they received the word with all
readiness and searched the scriptures
daily to find out whether these things
were so you can find that in acts 17 11.
so our challenge to you is to also
discover if the things that we say are
so
look it up for yourself we're not trying
to hide anything
you could say that goes with the theme
of our show light exposing darkness
we're living in a day and age where we
believe the words of deuteronomy ring
true the secret things belong to the
lord our god but those things which are
revealed belong to us and our children
forever that we may do all the words of
this law
it is our purpose and aim to uplift
christ and to point people to the words
of the bible as they evaluate their
world and the times that we live in so
they can be ready for jesus to come
i want to leave you with this thought
from the book of job
behold
this we have searched out it is true
hear it and know for yourself
well i hope that answers your question
feel free to reach out to us with your
other questions and you can do that
through our website or social media make
sure you take a look at the other
questions that we already answered on
youtube and god bless you as you search
for the truth which will set you free
[Music]
you